with all the social media outrage
directed to Airlines recently it's very
easy to understand why passengers are
boarding the plane ready to be pissed
off but if you're flying anywhere
anytime soon let's make a suggestion
okay please don't take your anger out on
the flight attendants flying is a
soul-crushing experience riverboat
remember flight attendants are also on a
12-hour flight dealing with the same
kamikaze scorpions and clip toenail
shrapnel that you are so please be nice
to them if for no other reason the fact
that they keep a secret when you go to
the bathroom near the break area and
take a nasty Cinnabon don't tell anybody
so comedians let's show some sympathy to
these brave men and women what is an
announcement a flight attendant would
like to make but never could Rhea
seehorn sorry that's just a bit of
turbulence or maybe not I don't know I
made my peace with God okay our pilot is
drunk off his ass and just saying oh my
[Laughter]